hey everybody it's Mike frieder with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week and you know what I'm gonna take
you behind the scenes on how I make
these videos well I just make them I
just Freestyle right off the top of my
head all right and you know what this
week we're gonna freestyle but not in
that way and we're gonna talk about cmmc
control
ca.l2-3.12.4 develop document and
periodically update system security
plans that describe system boundaries
system environments of operation how
security requirements are implemented
and the relationships with or connection
to other systems I couldn't find
something more exciting to talk about if
I tried
[Music]
thank you
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmoc
Deep Bars and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news you
found your home here in on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's dig into
it okay so cmmc control
ca.l2-3.12.4 I know you're excited to be
here we're kind of a little bit like
we're close to the end there's only two
more control families to go
you've watched a lot of my videos
haven't you yeah
develop document and periodically update
system security plans that describe
system boundaries system environments of
operation how security requirements are
implemented and the relationships with
or connections to other systems it's a
really really really long way of
basically saying hey you need to write a
system security plan and it would
probably be a lot easier if they just
gave you the format right but
you have to go find that yourself
well they sort of they sort of give it
to you but anyway this control really
defines everything you are supposed to
be delivering in your system security
plan if you're one of those people who
just went through the controls in the
SSP and didn't look at the top few
sections oh boy an assessor is going to
have a rude awakening for you my friend
there is a lot of documentation required
Beyond just these controls in order to
prove that your system is properly
documented so again if you're one of the
people and again I'm guilty of it too
when I first look at this thing all I
went and did is I went I look on my holy
crap 110 controls I'm gonna be here for
a little while and then you figure out
that like okay we can get through these
but then
you go I'm finished and then you realize
oh man there's like four pages of
requirements before you even get to the
first control so fair warning read the
whole thing okay or you just call us and
we take care of it for you all right
let's get into the details of what the
assessors are looking for here to make
sure you got a system security plan oh
my God that's really small font and I
think this is the one you're talking
about but anyway the point is I'm gonna
try to read you like these 15 different
assessment points and they're really
small so if I look like I'm squinting
it's because I am because that's how we
roll there's no time for editing here
just roll with it all right what are
they looking for all right first thing
is determine if a system security plan
is developed uh well
give me your system security plan just
show it to them show me the money right
that's all we got to do there all right
second thing they're looking for
determine if the system boundary is
described and documented in the system
security plan well look the way we do is
we have a little line that says see
attached documentation and we just like
dump a folder right onto the assessor
okay so again you're gonna have your
full you know all of your Baseline
configurations all your network diagrams
all of your system inventories like all
the stuff that they're asking for in the
first two sections of the system
security plan you just say here here you
go go through it there's your proof it's
there you do have that right like
everything in your network is totally
documented the way it's supposed to be
right
hope so it's not you know who to call
they'll call song call for nothing all
right Point number three they're looking
for to determine if the system
environment of operation is described
and documented in the system security
plan so again you're really just showing
up documentation here's the good news
I'm going to tell you the assessment
points here but the answer is going to
be the same you better show them the
evidence you better show them the money
you better show them those system
security plans and all the supporting
documentation there all right session
Point number four determine if the
security requirements identified and
approved by the designated Authority as
non-applicable are identified so again
if there is an authority okay and if
there are security requirements uh that
have been identified and that they are
improved as non-applicable so in other
words this is all the N A stuff in your
plan you see there's like three boxes
there's like implemented not implemented
then n a we really try hard to not have
anything n a because that gets super
questioned uh by any assessor because
they're like well surely this applies to
you uh ultimately again they're going to
want to know who's the authoritative
person that allowed you to put n a there
as an answer and let's go talk to that
person I know this is like really fun
isn't it uh so again we're going to show
the documentation and it's probably for
that one it's probably gonna be an
interview with the person who may be an
authority maybe it's an I.T director
maybe they got to go above the it
director's head if that's the guy that
filled out the plan but again they're
just going to want to check in and say
hey is it cool this is not applicable
does this make sense in your environment
and again it's more of a conversation
more of an interview style thing
next one determine if the method of
security requirement implementation
is described and documented in the
system security plan I'm going to make a
little joke here because whoever wrote
this stuff okay whoever wrote These
requirements definitely did not adhere
to the politicians third grade reading
level requirement all right method of
security requirement implementation I
don't know what that means I'm just not
that smart but somebody on my staff
figured out that's the good news all
right because I got a really amazing
team and they figure everything out for
you guys now what's the answer to this
one again we're just going to say hey go
see the documentation okay the
documentation is where the answers to
all of this are going to lie it's going
to be how we do what we do on this
particular assessment point so again I
can't tell you what it means I can just
tell you what the answer is I'm just
kidding guys you know what the rule is
go see the documentation now the next
assessment Point determine if the
relationship with or connection to other
systems is described and documented in
the system security plan so again yes
that's why I don't know if you guys have
seen the video but we have a video that
talks about you know us contra virtually
inserting definitions into the first
part of our system security plan we
always do it and our goal actually is
not because it's required but because it
just makes the Assessor's life easier
well interestingly we got this idea from
this assessment point right because if
we can show the relationship which you
can't necessarily show by answering the
control questions then we give them some
rationale about where it should be so
again you're going to say that's
implemented see the documentation it's
going to be basically an assessor
reviewing what you've got there and yes
in your system security plan you should
have boundaries described you should
have all these things done already in
your network documentation if you don't
have it if you're struggling to put
together Network documentation feel free
to call us okay we can definitely help
out with that now next assessment Point
determine if the frequency to update the
system security plan is defined ah now
this is an interesting one it turns out
not only do we have to have a system
security plan but we also have to have a
designated interval where we're actually
updating this and this is where um again
I'll kind of speak just how we solve it
we have this thing called a virtual
compliance officer service it's amazing
basically we come in and run compliance
for our clients because there are just
so many assessment points that you're
going to be evaluated on that are
dependent upon you integrating this as a
part of your day-to-day operation here's
an example you literally have to be
updating your system security plan you
have to have that sort of defined
frequency
which also translates into someone's got
to do it so if it's not gonna be someone
on your team it can be someone on our
team or our team will actually do the
review with you which is what we do a
lot of times during our quarterly risk
management meetings and other uh other
forms where it makes sense to actually
go and look at and review system
security plans and make sure they're
updated how often do you do that you
know what I'm gonna be honest with you
they don't really Define that precisely
but I will say for sure once a year
probably a little bit more often than
that if you're a larger company uh
typical thing we do with large clients
is usually a quarterly so a lot of
information there okay determinive
system security plan is updated with the
defined frequency so again making sure
the system security plan actually does
get implemented excuse me updated from
time to time and of course again we can
reflect back to various forms of
documentation such as you know again if
you do it in a risk management if you do
it in a DeForest nist meeting whatever
you choose your Forum to be to review
all of this that would be where you
would do this updating and also where
you would Define the frequency of how
often it's done now if your head is
spinning from all the stuff you didn't
even know that you had to actually do
the system security plan or you just
wish you didn't have to be watching my
videos while you're running on the
treadmill or riding your bike or
riding into work or whatever you do when
you listen to me talk about this
incredibly exciting subject matter the
good news is we help people just like
you you we can end the struggle you and
me all you got to do
is go to cmmccomplianceeekers.com that's
it that's all you gotta do you go to the
website schedule some time with one of
my experts these guys are awesome
They're Gonna Roll with you and they're
going to take care of everything start
to finish okay because we work with
defense contractors just like you who've
had all this defars nist itar and CMC
compliance stuff dropped onto their
heads like I see go on a sunny day and
it's not fun you wish you could seagull
on somebody else seagull on us we love
it we're like a mushroom we put us in
the dark and feed us you know what and
we're going to grow and Blossom into
something beautiful that's going to
fertilize your lawn
while we teach you how to level up and
be a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminated gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
and that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links that'll help you
get help right now you don't have to
wait you don't have to wait for the
mushroom to bloom we can go for it right
now it's like your one-up token
I might have seen the Mario movie with
my kids this weekend all right if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button hit the latest
compliance content as soon as our
complianceers roll it out
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there and hit
us in the comments below to let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you